ryan white
mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché parce que j'ai tiré sur
l'ambulance
je dois faire voeu de pénitence alors
comme ça vous pensez que je tire sur
l'ambulance
petit joueur petit joueur vous allez
voir qu'aujourd'hui on va être des
champions du tirage sur ambulance non
vous avez été très généreux de m'envoyer
plein de vidéos à des bouquets de
créationnistes suite aux dernières
vidéos que j'ai fait d'eux des bonnes
cage de créationnistes notamment le
dernier des bonnes kg pénitence où on
m'accuse de tirer violemment sur
l'ambulance parce que apparemment ce
serait trop facile de débarquer des
créationnistes aussi bas de plafond
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est d'être
bas de plafond
vous ne savez pas encore vous n'avez
même aucune idée mes bien chers abonnés
je vous présente le boss final d
internet le boss final du créationnisme
sur internet
petit petit très fort antoine daniel
juste pour se donner le sourire avant de
commencer ça parce que le sourire vous
allez le perdre il va fondre votre
sourire comme la neige au sommet de
cette montagne sérieusement cette vidéo
elle va vous faire pleurer pourquoi
parce que vous m'avez comme je les dis
envoyé plein de vidéos avec des
argumentaires créationnistes plus ou
moins bien construit plus ou moins
malhonnête faut toujours être un peu
malhonnête de toute façon pour être
créationnistes
mais ces vidéos vous m'avez envoyé elles
font des heures cd argumentaire
développé
donc ça déjà ça me prendrait des plombes
à des banques et c'est pour ça que je ne
les ferai probablement pas le dire il me
faut il me faut déjà deux heures pour
des bonnes 15 minutes de vidéo alors
vous imaginez si je m'attaquais des
vidéos d'une heure et demie mais bref
c'est surtout que ces vidéos elles sont
intelligentes comparé à ce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui et surtout surtout ce
qu'elles ont ces vidéos c'est qu'elles
n'ont quasiment pas de succès en tout
cas pas plus que notre chaîne à l'heure
actuelle ce qui est une des règles de
damon kg pénitence il faut avoir plus de
succès que notre propre chaîne et les
vidéos que vous m'envoyez elles sont
très bien avec des argumentaires qui
sont très intéressants à des banquiers
oui mais elles ne font que quelques
milliers de vues
voici mesdames et messieurs la plus
grande découverte de tous les temps avec
un thé l'arche de noé retrouver
226 1280 une vue là on parle là on
discute là il ya du level la ja du boss
final là là là on l'a on discute là
c'est pas juste quelques milliers de vue
là 200000 vu qu'elle fait cette vidéo la
200000 vu les argumentaires
créationnistes n'intéresse personne pas
même les créationnistes les
créationnistes ce qu'ils veulent c'est
du bête c'est du méchant c'est du bateau
et en parlant de bateaux
c'est parti pour l'arche de noé
m de nouveaux de chanel ça fait penser à
m gibbs
après antoine daniel ligne the sun
maintenant
daniel tient encore antoine daniel toi
antoine daniel tient secrètes ses
paroles et celle le livre jusqu'au temps
de la fin plusieurs alors le liront et
la connaissance augmentera
oui alors contrairement à ce que ça a
l'air de faire quoi il parle bien de la
bible ta connaissance augmentera lol
ranger baugé beau pas être
fondamentalement militants athées ou
anti croyants
ce qui a écrit dans la bible est un
tissu de contradictions
il faut bien se l'admettre le dire même
en étant croyant il faut bien se
l'admettre ce qu'il y a écrit dans les
livres sacrés en général c'est
généralement un tissu de contradictions
je veux dire ce qui est dit à un endroit
et contredit à un autre forcément parce
que c'est déjà des livres tellement gros
qu'ils racontent des histoires tellement
différentes que de toute façon je dire
ça a été écrit par tellement de monde
aussi différence n'a pas été écrit par
dieu les livres sacrés ils ont été
écrits par des gens et ça a été écrit
par tellement de monde différent avec
tellement de philosophie différente a
tellement d'époques différentes que vous
trouverez forcément la contradiction
d'une idée plus loin ou avant dans le
bouquin donc les livres sacrés sont des
tissus de contradictions de manière
générale donc augmenter votre
connaissance avec des tissus de
contradictions c'est pas évident donc
c'est pas parce que je suis
fondamentalement anti croyant que je dis
ça c'est pas parce que je crois que
fondamentalement la bible c'est que des
conneries non c'est parce que de manière
générale les livres sacrés le dire il ya
forcément un moment où ils se
contredisent
surtout sur toutes les idées donc bref
vous allez être témoin d'une découverte
garder secrète une découverte qui
dérange une alors une découverte gardée
secrète
j'aimerais j'aimerais quand même qu'on
mette au point quelque chose une
découverte gardée secrète
il s'apprête à nous l'a montré sur
google maps
à votre avis quel est le niveau de
secret de cette découverte
c'est une découverte secrète c'est un
oxymoron je tiens à souligner au passage
une découverte c'est forcément pas
secret ça a été rendu public une
découverte
on peut pas être découverts et secret à
la fois
cc c'est emmerdant
une découverte
orange ça n'a pas l'air de déranger les
200000 vu ça a pas l'air de déranger la
plupart des gens qui l'ont vu ta vidéo
d'ailleurs regardez jusqu'à la fin
abonne toi clic la cloche
regardez bien cette montagne comme il le
faut
elle est pointue oh mais c'est la
musique de batman
c'est là il y a de la neige en abondance
sur son sommet dit il sur une musique
épique de batman
alors là il va vous faire croire qu'il
est allé sur place mais ce n'est pas une
vidéo est lui sain cette montagne est
situé dans un désert sec et aride du
moyen-orient
t'es tu vas pas tu vas pas partir dans
cette direction curieuse qui va être de
nous dire que il fait trop chaud pour
qu'il ya de la neige c'est forcément un
miracle par pitié
par pitié ne va pas dans cette direction
transition puisque vous noterez ce fondu
enchaîné
pour remettre la même image derrière sur
la musique de fond plus le montage le
dire mais franchement il ya certaines de
mes vidéos j'ai un peu honte parce que
le montage est vraiment est vraiment
minime mais faire du montage pour en
arriver là c'est beau ça devient de
l'art à ce niveau là
avec google earth on peut
clairement de la neige sur son sommeil
jusqu'à environ 1000 km de distance dans
les airs ça ressemble à une traduction
un peu crasse donc donc le grand secret
c'est que c'est une montagne avec de la
neige et ça c'est bien celle h en
maintenant dans le secteur du
moyen-orient une autre montagne de la
même envergure est aussi enneigés qui
pourrait être comparable à notre modèle
bar en v'là une dire si c'est pas de la
neige ça c'est quoi ça alors mesdames
messieurs les géographes non ça c'est
une ville mais pourquoi tu la gardes et
au montage non plus bas c'est pareil
c'est un peu blanc quand même comment tu
fais la différence entre de la neige et
du caillou blanc sur sur google earth
messieurs dames les géographes on
s'accroche on s'accroche bien
vous avez étudié toute votre vie bande
d'enfoirés huit ans d'études
une thèse de géographie alors que la
bonne réponse c'était d'aller sur google
earth de faire des allers-retours sur
google earth et de dire mais regardez
les montagnes l ont pas de neige c'est
un miracle regardez la montagne elle a
de la neige c'est forcément c'est
forcément divin comme intervention
et de rajouter une musique de batman par
dessus mais oui mais oui évidemment
c'est comme ça que ça se fait la science
c'est tout à fait comme ça que ça se
fait et de clamer qu'on a fait une
découverte
tu clames que tu as fait une découverte
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait une
montagne avec de la neige sur google
earth et personne ne nous l'a appris à
l'école sa personne c'est une découverte
secrète oui madame
allez on continue d aller retour
j'espère que vous n'avez pas le mal de
mer des milliers de kilomètres parcourus
aucune montagne correspondant à notre
modèle initial alors c'est un exemple
magnifique de cherry picking
effectivement enfin je veux dire il fait
des allers retours aux endroits qu'ils
arrangent bien en disant regardez il n'y
a pas de neige sur les montagnes
alentours bon qu'est ce que c'est que ce
qu'est ce que c'est que cette façon de
faire n'a qu'à ce que c'est que cette
façon de faire y a pas de neige autour
bas peut-être parce qu'elle pose
montagne aussi grande autour banane le
dire à la une on est en train de nous
montrer des toutes petites collines
qu'est ce que tu racontes mec va dans
l'himalaya temps verra des montagnes
avec de la neige dessus et à la même
latitude 1 à la même latitude
alors c'est tellement épique comme
musique je le laisse juste pour la
musique pour la musique et pour le
ridicule quoi ça en faire ma trésorerie
no id unique d'une importance capitale
pour le monde entier
cette montagne parce qu'elle a de la
neige renferme un trésor inouïe une voix
indépendante
l'épaisseur de neige et de glace est
l'élément clé qui a permis de conserver
son trésor jusqu'à notre ère mais qu'est
ce que c'est la petite bien-être c'est
dans le titre c'est l'arche de noé lui
il croit qu'il a trouvé l'arche de noé
dans dans la neige
alors juste juste alors on va prendre
donc cette montagne bon je vous fais un
spoiler tout de suite c'est le mont
ararat tu donc à ras rate
voilà c'est le mont ararat de cette
montagne et donc si on la met sur google
maps 1
on va voir qu'il ya d'autres montagnes
enneigées qui se trouve à exactement la
même latitude
c'est pas la seule montagne enneigée du
coin déjà vous avez l'arménie
l'azerbaïdjan juste au dessus là je veux
dire ça c'est bourré de montagnes
enneigées
faut pas déconner non plus je veux dire
donc l'arménie voilà juste à côté un des
milliers de kilomètres parcourus tu n'as
pas pensé à aller en arménie sur le
monde sur le mont sa dague
je n'ai aucune idée de comment ça se
prononce voilà milliers de kilomètres
parcourus vous n'avez pas eu l'idée
d'aller plus juste un tout petit peu au
nord en arménie et puis évidemment on
même latitude vous allez voir qu'il ya
des montagnes qui sont enneigées pouf au
au tadjikistan voilà un même l'attitude
du tadjikistan c'est plein de neige
ah bah merde alors mais alors cela le
tadjikistan mais cela voudrait-il dire
que je me suis trompé et je vous
garantis à vous je vous disais au début
vous croyez que je tire sur l'ambulance
mais il ya des vidéos
il ya des contenus sur internet qui ont
beaucoup plus de succès que ce que je
vous montre et qui sont beaucoup plus
mauvais que vous ne pouvez l'imaginer
là on n'est même plus et même pu tirer
sur l'ambulance la cdu bazooka lance
roquettes missiles stinger sur sur
l'ambulance majorettes vous savez les
petites voitures les voitures est grande
comme ça là ah là là c'est une
annihilation je dire c'est le déblocage
le plus nul de toute l'histoire que je
vais vous faire je vous annonce tout de
suite la couleur
si vous voulez voir de la science
intelligente passez votre chemin
ça va être un massacre c'est tout toi
qui est venu ici en imaginant voir un
des bonnes cash constructif
passe ton chemin passe ton chemin petit
ici c'est le sang les larmes et la merde
et du rire et du rire évidemment se
prend pas au sérieux mais oui on se
prend pas au sérieux
et oui je force mourir parce que j'aime
bien rire c'est bon de rire pendant le
confinement
t'as pas envie de rire bref
cette neige perdurent sur la montagne
depuis des millénaires pour notre
génération donc la foule finalisme le
finalisme de l'enfer c'est un peu fort
alors je baisse le son constatez par
vous même
aucune autre montagne ni est comparable
dans tout le moyen-orient a rejoint que
vous montrez le tadjikistan s'est pas
suffisamment s'est pas suffisamment dans
le moyen-orient et le tadjikistan
peut-être très très nul en géographie
mais en tout cas c'est la même latitude
donc voilà il ya des montagnes enneigées
la même latitude 100 mètres d'épaisseur
de glace uniquement pour cette montagne
pour protéger le trésor qu'elle enferme
voilà la belle tournure biya sauvagement
finalistes sens
peut-être montagne sans cette neige et
sans cette montagne il garde le suspense
le trésor n'aurait pu traverser les
siècles donc vous avez compris que la
montagne est unique en hauteur grosseur
et localisation mais oui mais oui donc
les montagnes on sait qu'elles poussent
pour préserver les trésors vous avez pas
dit mais toute la tectonique des plaques
tout ça c'est faux c'est faut laisser
tomber la tectonique des plaques la
géologie des points chauds le volcanisme
comment se forment les montagnes tout ça
c'est faux c'est faux les montagnes elle
pousse pour préserver des arches de noé
n'avez rien compris
vous n'avez rien compris
cette haute montagne s'appelle rabat en
train de tout rater cette europe
montagne s'appelle le mont ararat tu qui
est située en turquie ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta alors accrochez-vous bien c'était la
seule information vraie de tout ce truc
cette montagne est le mont ararat tu
sais à peu près la seule information
véridique qu'il va balancer le plus
surprenant est que cette montagne porte
encore son nom depuis le tout début de
l'humanité
elle porte le même nom depuis le tout
début de l'humanité
peut-être parce que les civilisation
indo européennes sont nés au
moyen-orient et que c'est eux qui ont
nommé les montagnes alentours
question un point d'interrogation alors
mont ararat tu wikipédia tu vas nous
dire qu'elle est litim au logis de mont
ararat tu mont ararat tweak ipdia ce qui
est bien c'est qu'il ya pas beaucoup à
faire des recherches 1 pour ça le nom
arabe citée dans la bible aurait
apparaît déjà sur une carte babylonienne
du monde qui évoque un royaume d'ararat
où humour art ou également mentionné
dans les sources assyrienne décrivant le
haut-plateau arménien à ce terme
réapparait en 2 3
l'annoncé des chapitres c'est des
passages de des versets de la bible mais
la tradition sémites associe ce nom au
monde joue dit précédemment appelé à
rades oussara
quoi qu'il en soit les traditions
arménienne puis européennes finissent
par rattacher le nom à ratoma si le plus
haut sommet identifié du plateau
arménien donc c'est certes le nom
d'ararat existait depuis longtemps mais
apparemment il n'a été rattachée à la
montagne que a posteriori donc voilà que
au final à force de tradition des
chrétiens d'armenia et d'europe
le nom en turquie ossements ossements
lit et est à gurs d'agde
c'est à dire la lourde montagne qui peut
être traduit par ailleirs d'agde en turc
moderne au caire est donc il s'appelle
pas il n'a pas toujours porté le nom d'
art ça le mot art as tu existes la
désignation arad existe dans la bible 1
mais s'était associé à une montagne à
une autre montagne le monde joue dit
e
ea dont on a une page aussi wikipedia le
monde je vous dis est selon la tradition
des premiers chrétiens dans l'islam la
soit l'endroit où l'arche de noé
s'oppose à l'identification du monde
jeudi comme lieu d'atterrissage de
l'arche perdue rats dans les traditions
syriaque arménienne jusqu'à l'antiquité
tardive mais fut ailleurs abandonné pour
une tradition qui situer le lieu
biblique sur la plus haute montagne de
la région le mot le mont ararat tu
voilà donc là c'est formidable ce qu'on
vient de lire on vient de nous dire
qu'en gros c'est pas la bonne montagne
donc alors le mont ararat tu ne sais pas
toujours appelé arrate déjà
contrairement à ce qu'il dit mais en
plus le le lieu d'atterrissage de
l'arche
traditionnellement c'est pas le mont
ararat tse une autre montagne qui
s'appelle le monde joue dit donc en gros
il est en train de nous dire fantastique
découverte de l'arche de noé sur le mont
ararat tu
bah non bon après c'est une affirmation
non sourcées on va lui laisser un point
quand même c'est une affirmation non
sourcées bien qu'après ils parlent tous
d'être addictions et tout ça et là ça
devient source est un art chupa arche
sur le monde joue guère en tout cas
c'est pas le mont ararat tu
et ça c'est plus qu'assez pour pour déjà
pour déjà pour déjà être très très très
sceptiques et soulever un sourcil un
sourcil circonspecte n'est ce pas bref
on continue on continue la vidéo avec
batman les montagnes d'ararat sont
mentionnés pour la toute première fois
dans l'histoire de la jeunesse le
premier livre de la bible apparemment
non apparemment c'est pas la même
montagne
voici le papa lé passage biblique qui en
fait mention et qui révèle ce qui se
cache sous cette montagne depuis le tout
début de la création
ah c'est tellement beau c'est tellement
lent aussi dieu se souvint de noé à
parce qu'il l'avait oublié de tous les
animaux et de tout le bétail qui étaient
avec lui dans l'arche et dieu fit passer
par avance sur la terre et les os à
peiser les sources de l'abîmé les
écluses des cieux furent fermées et la
plus de tomba plus du ciel les eaux se
retirèrent du dessus de la terre s'en
allant et s'éloignant les eaux diminué
au bout de 50 de 50 jours le septième
mois le 17e jour du mois l'arche
s'arrêta sur les montagnes d'ararat les
eaux à l'air en diminuant jusqu'à
dixième mois le premier jour du mois
apparurent les sommets des montagnes
d'accord donc
donc en fait c'est a posteriori donc si
je recoupe ça avec eux ce qu'ils
disaient sur wikipédia c'est donc à
postériori qu'ils ont déterminé que la
montagne la plus haute de la région
était le mont arafat
d'après ce qui était écrit dans la bible
parce qu'évidemment la bible ne dit pas
où se trouve le mont ararat tu 27 avril
à l'arche de noé a été retrouvé alors il
va parler de ce reportage chinois
l'intérieur
delage de noël se trouvait sur le monde
arabe à 4000 mètres d'altitude
donc le mec s'étonne quand même que 4000
mètres d'altitude il ya de la neige
c'est quand même assez balèze
c'est quand même assez balèze donc
intérieur de large retrouvé mois au
moins cette découverte dérange et ne
fait aucunement écho dans les médias
internationaux lors il est en train de
nous montrer les images d'un
documentaire pour ça c'est tellement
c'est tellement ignorer tu vois que
c'est les images d'un documentaire
avec un site internet et/ou 1
qu'est-ce que c'était quoi ça c'était
quoi ce temps je vais passer en plein
écran
parti d'un câble vieux de 4800 ans d'un
câble un câble il ya quatre mille huit
cents ans un câble mais il avait il
avait le wifi évidemment falloir il
n'avait pas besoin de lui il n'avait pas
le wifi il avait la fibre directement il
avait la fibre optique
voici tout ce qui va nous montrer
l'évolution cerise remise en question
assurément alors alors je t'annonce
petit scarabée petit scarabée tu vas
prendre ta leçon maintenant le fait qu
un gugusse est à un moment pendant une
inondation mis des couples d'animaux
dans une barque
à aucun moment ça remet en question la
théorie de l'évolution à aucun moment je
suis tout à fait prêt à admettre qu'un
jour un bon monsieur nommé noé a
construit un gros bateau et amis des
couples d'éléphants de lyon puis toussa
toussa dessus et qu'il est parti voguer
qui s'est crashé sur une montagne après
la fin des inondations
aucun problème moi j'ai aucun problème
avec ça par contre mais ça ne remet
absolument pas en compte la théorie de
l'évolution 1
de même que si demain moi je prends une
barque et que je mets des couples
d'animaux dessus ça remettra absolument
pas en question la théorie de
l'évolution
donc non en quoi la en quoi prouver que
la théorie de l'arche de noé enfin en
quoi prouver que l'arche de noé existe
remet en question la théorie de
l'évolution
un nom parce qu au nom il ya des images
de darwin qui arrive après pourquoi
pourquoi arrêter foutez la paix à darwin
il a rien fait ça fait cent cinquante
ans qu'il est mort foutez lui la paix
dans ça fait le sang je sais plus je
m'en fous foutez la paix à darwin c'est
tout
ban qui s'est pas trompé l'intérieur de
l'arche de noé trouvé sur le moins
arrête les gens ont le droit de croire
qu'ils descendent du sage
non les gens ont raison de penser qu'ils
ont un ancêtre commun avec le japon le
chimpanzé une fois de plus c'est
sauf que si l'homme descend du singe
pourquoi le singe existe encore
aujourd'hui non non non
cette question existe aujourd'hui c'est
pas vrai voilà ça c'est le genre
typiquement le genre de questions mais
je me dis mais c'est pas possible c'est
du troll cette vidéo
c'est forcément du troll tu peux pas
faire une vidéo comme ça et être sérieux
mais même si c'est du troll de toute
façon on regarde et on va voir dans
l'est là dedans bon il ya mon
commentaire à moins évidemment le
problème je veux dire le problème c'est
que même si c'est du troll parce que
évidemment qu'il y en a dans parmi vous
qui vont me dire que c'est du troll mais
même si c'est du troll il ya des gens
qui croient et regarder des like il ya
beaucoup de plus de gens qui croient que
de gens qui n'y croient pas regarder le
nombre de vues regardez le nombre de
vues regardez le nombre de commentaires
qui trouve ça intéressant
l'arche de noé bon là j'en ai chialé de
rire il ya comme tout le monde ne tombe
pas dans le panneau heureusement il ya
quand même un paquet de gens qui croient
quoi je veux dire donc que c'est quand
même assez ouf quoi de voir que tra
que ces trucs là ça passe quoi donc même
si c'est du troll même si c'est du troll
c'est du terrorisme
c'est du terrorisme intellectuel parce
que ça à son effet sur les gens ça ça
passe quand même pour certains mais que
c'est ici et voilà et l'homme descend du
singe alors pourquoi les singes
existe-t-il encore aujourd'hui bas c'est
la même raison pour là et je vais donner
la même réponse que je donne à chaque
fois les sages existe encore aujourd'hui
pour la même raison que
que ta mère n'a pas disparu quand elle
t'a donné naissance et que ta grand mère
non plus n'a pas soudainement disparu
voilà ne s'est pas volatilisé quand elle
t'a donné naissance voilà c'est vous
avez d'un côté pas je me dis même en
admettant que l'homme descend du singe
ce qui n'est pas strictement vrai mais
même en admettant que l'homme descend du
singe comme je descends de ma mère vous
avez le sage vous avez l'homme qui sort
du singe et puis vous avez un homme et
un singe c'est pour ça qu'il existe
encore des singes donc même en partant
de l'affirmation fausses
enfin pas tout à fait vrai je peux quand
même vous dire pourquoi comment ça
marche
donc bon waouh
pas à pas cette question c'est normal
mais dans un état de sa me ça me met
dans une sorte de fûts soir imaginez
même pas
des morceaux de bois je préfère être un
enfant de dieu que 2 décembre d'un singe
doté de peu d'intelligence être un
enfant de dieu ne fait pas forcément de
toi quelqu'un d'intelligent
il y a tellement de gens il ya tellement
de gens crétins sur terre et ce sont
tous des enfants de dieu tu sais et
peut-être que tu en fais un peu partie
peut-être peut-être pas c'est pareil
comment tu peux écrire ça sérieusement
enfin je veux dire si c'est du troll
ou alors combien de temps il va me
falloir en google en documentaire
chinois arche de noé documentaire essayé
d'écrire documentaire comme il faut
chinois je donnerais avant de découvrir
que ce truc n'est jamais sorti et que
cette info
ce que je fais pas je n'ai jamais vu one
internity la terre après moult et moult
recherches des fausses pistes suivies la
recherche de ce documentaire sur l'arche
de noé ce documentaire chinois sur large
de noël j'ai fini par trouver le titre
du documentaire en question donc ils
s'appellent de dave noah 2 apocalypse
qui date de 2011 effectivement the days
off noah 2 apocalypse est ce que vous
trouvez que ça c'est un titre de
documentaires c'est ça à titre de de
vieux films d'action série b production
asylum quoi donc
c'est ça le titre du documentaire
documentaire qui alors j'imagine est
sorti en dvd mais apparemment ça doit
pas être de là qu'il a qu'il a extrait
les images vues la qualité mais
apparemment il existe en dvd ce
documentaire donc si jamais si jamais
quelqu'un le là si jamais quelqu'un l'a
vu si jamais quelqu'un le sait où le
trouver pourquoi pas ça peut être un
visionnage plutôt marrant avec beaucoup
de bière mais alors là où ça devient
marrant c'est que
quand on voit dans la page wiki pétanque
cherche sur wikipédia à propos de ce
documentaire sur la page anglaise de
wikipedia parce que ça ne l'est pas sur
la page française
il y a un petit paragraphe qui parlent
que en 2007 une équipe turque au congrès
est allé alors donc avec les membres de
la noise ark ministries international
donc la nami donc noah's ark ministries
international je peux aussi vous avez
fait gaffe mais c'est ce qui a décrit
ici ça se voit un peu la trouille de la
gandhi à la noaa ark ministries
international donc il s'agit bien d'eux
voilà
a prétendu avoir trouvé une grotte avec
du bois à l'intérieur et des dents sur
le mot art as tu bien au dessus de la
ligne de végétation donc dans le glacier
typiquement en 2010
ils ont fait une vidéo de leurs
découvertes et des des structures en
bois
les membres de la nami
disent avoir fait des datation
radiocarbone qui suggère que le bois à
4800 en datation ramon gars radiocarbone
je vous le donne en mille
on les a jamais vu un de dire gg
cherchait déjà vous en faites pas pour
ça que j'ai fait une coupure c'est à
dire on les a jamais vus et il n'est pas
possible qu'il y ait eu des occupations
humaines à cette altitude au dessus de
4000 m donc 10 10 quelqu'un dans un
journal en 2010 randall price un
partenaire donc de jazz avec ministry a
dit que la découverte était probablement
le résultat d'un faux c'est quand même
dommage ça hein
randall prize qui est donc un partenaire
de ces gens là des gens qui ont fait le
documentaire de 2008 et qui a été membre
en 2008 dit que c est probablement le
résultat d'un faux perpétrés par des
kurdes des travailleurs kurdes
engagé par les turcs qui ont guidé les
chinois et qui ont donc planté des gros
morceau de tronc d'arbre pris d'autres
vieilles structures près de la mer morte
dans une grotte ça serait quand même
assez choquant mais bon alors les
sources de ça
voilà donc c'est encore dans un journal
ex-collègue expéditions alors la source
de sa c'est noah's ark found
peut-être que l'article n'existe plus ça
du match
en tout cas bref on va continuer on ira
voir ça après dans une réponse à price
donc nami a dit qu'ils n'avaient ils
terminaient leur coopération avec price
donc un petit exemple de censure à
l'ancienne
mais allez voir les trucs en bois qu'ils
ont identifiées
et qu'il regrette son absence sur leur
site web
demander à l'opinion de monsieur mu du
luth le directeur du ministère de la
culture et de la province d'agri donc là
où se trouve la structure le site web
dit que la réponse a été
secrètement non say that is responses
date secrète liedson sporting sociaux
namhong timber tout de ce truc les
moniteurs arias une planting la route
structure est en altitude
ouais donc ils disent que ce serait
impossible d'implanter des des rondins
aussi au coi de transporter des rondins
de si loin et aussi haut ça reste
raisonnable et à la fin de 2010
il a été rapporté que le ministère de la
culture turque a fait des sondages dans
ce qu'on a mis à trouver pour avoir des
des échantillons de bois
c'est toujours la source c'est toujours
le même article celui là un explorer et
causé un explorer écossais s'élancer a
trait à la recherche de l'arche reporté
par par un ami le 14 octobre 2010 et il
a disparu apparemment et apparemment il
a disparu
c'est ma théorie du complot
ces genres on échange de retrouver leur
arche et pouf il a disparu
c'est marrant et donc donc jusqu'à
présent bas personne d'autre donc ce
qu'il faut tirer de ce paragraphe
apparemment c'est qu'il y a des
datations au carbone 14 personne ne les
a jamais vus il existe une arche
personne à part les gens qui ont fait
leurs portes avec des gens qui ont fait
2 le documentaire nom l'ont vu
apparemment qu'il y a des gens au sein
de leurs propres organisations qui
disent que c'est un fake ou qu'il y en a
au moins un et qu'il a été grassement
licenciés et qui a un mec il ya qu un
seul mec pour l'instant qui a essayé de
retrouver la même structure et il a
disparu
donc on ne sait donc personne d'autre
n'a jamais vu sa structure on va pas
tomber dans la théorie du complot
évidemment mais on va juste rester sur
donc il n'y a jamais personne
d'indépendants à ce documentaire qui n'a
vu cette structure voilà et c'était en
2010 et ça a fait grand bruit et il ya
eu un gigantesque documentaire et ils
ont vendu des dvd donc la thune ils
l'ont 1 donc ou quelle est la grosse
découverte ou qu'ils aient le goût qu'il
est le follow up là où kiêu qu'il est
passé l'argent rendez l'argent c'est
voilà qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est
ce qui s'est passé sérieusement et donc
il ya sept cet article ici donc là c'est
là où il ya les déclarations de randall
price un archéologie un archéologue donc
lui apparemment cet havre archéologues
qui travaillait avec les chinois a dit
au christian science monitor donc un
journal chrétien apparemment mon
problème c'est que à la fin des analyses
pourraient montrer que tout ça n'était
qu'un faux et que cela pourrait refléter
cela cela pourrait donner une image très
naïve de la communauté chrétienne en
gros voilà donc
donc il ya même des gens des gens qui
sont censés être créationnistes un
qu'ils disent
quand même des gens qui sont
créationnistes qui ont tout intérêt à y
croire qu'ils disent à peut-être pas y
croire là il ya un autre donc bill
course président de la crise tiennent
une formation ministre qui a lui-même
passé des années à la recherche de l'art
de l'arche
mon problème c'est que même en voulant
bien faire les christian jump jump the
gun donc il se jette sur l'opportunité
que ça devient virale sur internet
beaucoup de christien sont désorientés
parce qu'il pensait que l'arche a été
trouvé il ya deux ans ou deux ans avant
ça et à peu près tous les deux ans en
gros y'a quelqu'un qui prétend avoir
trouvé l'arche
[Rires]
voilà donc c'est balèze quand même donc
là il rappelle du coup qu'en 1993 il ya
déjà un documentaire qui avait prétendu
avoir trouvé l'arche et puis finalement
c'était pas ça donc bref même les gens
même les gens qui sont censés y croire
qu'ils ont tout intérêt à y croire
n'avais pas envie d'y croire
et puis ben depuis rien de plus n'est
sorti voilà tout ce qu'on peut penser de
des documentaires d'où sortent ces
images et quand vous regardez ces images
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que ce
qu'on y voit
c'est toujours des plans très serré vous
ne verrez jamais de plan qui montre une
gigantesque salle parce que c'est quand
même censé être large de nourrir c'est
censé être l'arche de noé c'est censé
être gigantesque vous ne verrez jamais
une salle entière de l'arche de noé
de plus donc si on en croit les analyses
carbone 14 1
ce que vous voyez là là ce plancher là
ce que vous voyez sur ce plan là c'est
un plancher qu'il restait quatre mille
ans sous la glace parce que pour que
l'arche de noé soient préservés on est
bien d'accord que elle s'est crashée sur
l'art sur le mont ararat tu as la fin du
déluge et ça a gelé tout de suite par
dessus pour que ce soit préservée comme
ça c'est le seul moyen vous entendez
comme le bois sonne un vous allez
entendre comme le bois sonne entendez ça
sonne comme de la planche moderne donc
le bois n'a pas fossilisées voilà c'est
toujours du bois c'est toujours du bois
donc la seule chance pour que du bois se
préserve pendant quatre mille ans comme
ça aussi parfaitement c'est qu'il est
resté dans la glace ce que la
normalement vous devez me suivre le bois
n'a pas pu survivre autrement que dans
la glace sauf qu'une structure comme
l'arche de noé dans un glacier un
glacier c'est vivant à un glacier ça
bouge bon c'est pas vivant au sens
littéral du terme mais un glacier ça
bouge ça avance ça recul ça fonce arjel
par dessus
bref votre arche de noé là aujourd'hui
il devrait plus y avoir une seule poutre
aligné comme ça là comme il vous montre
là çà çà çà çà c'est impossible ça je
veux dire l'arche de noé l'ailé elle est
tellement grande que les différentes
parties du glacier l'aurait réduit en
charpie
c'est impossible qu'il ya que ces
structures là qui vous montre soit aussi
bien préservés ça c'est une cabane de ça
c'est une cabane de berger dans un
glacier ça c'est pas c'est pas une arche
de noé
regardez comme c'est beaucoup trop
parfaitement préservé le c'est
impossible alors et je reviens à ça on
ne descend aucunement du sage
en quoi l'existence de larges de noël
remet en question l'existence de
l'évolution ça il vous l'expliquera
jamais facile dans l'absolu je vois bien
le raisonnement le raisonnement sebhaoui
l'arche de noé existe c'est une preuve
que le récit de noé et est vrai donc
c'est une preuve que tout ce qu'il ya
dans la bible est vrai enfin tout ce
qu'il ya dans les livres sacrés en
général est vrai puisque c'est une
histoire qu'on retrouve aussi dans dans
la torah et dans le coran
donc ces livres sacrés son vrai donc la
genèse est vrai donc il n'y a pas
d'évolution voyez là comme bien fallu
que j'ai tire le raisonnement là je veux
dire même en admettant que l'arche de
noé existe ça veut pas dire que le récit
biblique de l'arche de noé est vrai déjà
d'une c'est pas parce que il ya
effectivement eu un jour un gus qui a
mis des animaux sur un bateau et que ce
gus s'appelait noah que ça fait
forcément de l'histoire qui est racontée
dans la bible une histoire vraie ça peut
être une version extrêmement romancée de
l'histoire vraie donc déjà d'une
premièrement même si ceci est réellement
l'arche de noé ça veut pas dire que le
récit de noé est vrai
deuxièmement le récit de noé
c'est pas parce que celui là est vrai
que le récit de la genèse est vrai un le
récit de la jeunesse c'est quand même
pousse tout est apparue en six jours on
est quand même sur un autre niveau de
mythologie et enfin fond rose écriture
écriture sur fond rose
je crois que même sur sur le logiciel le
plus basique de montage que tu puisses
faire il ne te propose pas l'option
écrire sur fond rose c'est beau il
aurait fallu écrire en times new roman
en en comics ans pour que ce soit encore
plus ridicule les adepte de la théorie
de l'évolution
il ya des chocs chose d'écrit en bas des
choses bien drôle les adeptes de la
théorie de l'évolution ont tous un
ancêtre en commun avec darwin
l'affirmation gratuite
l'affirmation super gratuite ils ont un
ancêtre commun avec darwin ce genre
c'est censé être une insulte ça savez
vous qui est l'arrière-arrière-arrière
grand-père de charles darwin
alors ça c'est ça c'est une image
d'ailleurs je la joue en profite et
charles darwin et la sélection naturelle
ça vient de la petite histoire si je me
rappelle bien match match match lleyton
alors c'est une chaîne qui s'appelait
pour la petite histoire mais je viens de
me rendre compte avec tristesse après
moult recherches que cette chaîne
n'existe plus apparemment
donc voilà la 404 introuvable donc pour
la petite histoire donc ses 16 bat pour
la petite histoire cette image ne sent
pas de nulle part c'est la chaîne pour
la petite histoire qu'il avait fait et
ce n'était évidemment pas contre darwin
que cette vidéo avait été produite
contrairement à ce que le ce contenu
créationnistes essaie de nous faire
croire
on continue donc savez vous qui est
l'arrière arrière grand père de charles
darwin
il va nous dire sérieusement
[Musique]
donc mesdames et messieurs son meilleur
argument contre la théorie de
l'évolution nous montrer un chimpanzé
qui danse voilà il ya deux cent mille
personnes qui donnent du crédit à cette
vidéo il ya des gens qui félicite
l'auteur de la vidéo 1
bah alors puisqu'on en parle alors c'est
certainement pas évidemment c'est
certainement pas l'arrière grand père de
charles darwin pour la simple et bonne
raison que charles darwin il a vécu
avant ce sage
donc c'est par ailleurs c'est par
ailleurs une magnifique des bonnes cage
de l'idée selon laquelle ses plus vieux
c'est forcément l'ancêtre là pour le
coup charles darwin est plus ancien que
le sage donc que le singe qu'on nous
montre là donc et charles darwin n'est
pourtant pas l'ancêtre de ce sage donc
bref c'est juste pour la petite anecdote
donc regardons ce sage c'est bien parce
qu'en plus on va avoir une dame juste
la raison avec homo sapiens donc ce
chimpanzé se tient présentement debout
il est donc capable d' une bipédie
temporaire piper dits temporaires dont
on sait où du mois dont on pense qu'elle
était commune à l'ancêtre en commun des
chimpanzés et de l'humain cela fait donc
un caractère entre en commun entre ce
chimpanzé et les êtres humains on
regarde la main du chimpanzé
on y voit un pouce opposable très
typique des primates cela fait donc deux
caractères en commun avec les humains si
vous ne me croyez pas vous pourrez
regarder les pouces opposables de cette
dame
juste au cas où vous ne riez pas
confiance en ce que je vous dis notez
l'expressivité du visage du chimpanzé
c'est un caractère que tous les primates
en commun donc ça fait 3 noter aussi la
forme des oreilles du chimpanzé comparer
les a des oreilles de chat comparer les
a des oreilles de renard de chiens de
cheval de vaches de n'importe quel autre
animal vous constaterez que la forme des
oreilles du chimpanzé quand même celle
qui lui ressemble le plus c'est les
oreilles des êtres humains
regardez la forme du pavillon auditifs
vous réduisez un petit peu l'échelle par
rapport à la taille du réduisait un peu
la taille par rapport à la taille du de
la tête en général ça vous donne
exactement la même forme que l'oreille
d'un humain forme d'oreilles qu'on ne
retrouve chez aucune autre espèce
enfin sachez qu'on retrouve chez
d'autres espèces de primates évidemment
mais en tout cas qu'on ne retrouve pas
ailleurs que chez les primates dont
l'homme fait partie
ici nous avons une belle bouche bien
ouverte donc ici on voit bien la canine
est ici on voit une deux trois quatre
incisive 4 incisive c'est typique aussi
de ce qu'on retrouve chez l'homme deux
paires d'incisives c'est aussi un
caractère qu'on retrouve en commun entre
ce chimpanzé et nous fait déjà 6 6
caractères qu'il ya en commun entre le
chimpanzé et nous hein donc non c'est
pas ton grand père c'est ton cousin
c'est ton cousin j'essaye edwards est
évidemment il ya le nez le nez 1
les chimpanzés n'ont pas de truffes et
ils n'ont pas de museau non plus les
chimpanzés honte à un museau qui est
très très court comme nous et 2,8 et
leur nez est un échec
il n'a pas de truffes comme un chien
comme elle émue rien comme bref comme la
plupart des animaux encore une fois donc
cette absence de truffe c'est aussi un
caractère qu'on retrouve chez les sages
chez les grands singes et chez l'homme
ça fait donc neuf caractère en commun
avec l'humain caractère qui ont tous été
héritée d'un d'ancêtres en commun voilà
le fait que le chimpanzé puisse se
frapper le gluten us comme ça c'est
précisément parce qu'il se tient debout
qui lag l'utérus proéminent c'est pas
pour rien non
mais bref et enfin ce charpente ou le
gag de cette séquence repose sur le fait
que le chimpanzé est capable de
reproduire les gestes des humains
reproduction des gestes des humains qui
vient de son intelligence intelligence
qu'il partage avec l'ancêtre enfin
intelligence qu'il partage avec nous et
avec l'ancêtre en commun que nous avons
avec le chimpanzé donc dans cette petite
séquence où on tourne soi-disant en
ridicule la théorie de l'évolution en
montrant à sage les sages c'est rigolo
que vous c'est pas sérieux les singes
comme s'ils s'étaient jamais crétins les
êtres humains tu sais bref donc c'est
pas sérieux les sages c'est rigolo les
sages et ben en fait on voit au moins
dix caractères en commun que les singes
ont avec les êtres humains et qui sont
soient apparus par hasard soit hérité
d'un ancêtre en commun
la troisième une possibilité c'est que
le grand créateur dans son infinie dans
son infinie volonté de nous trop laid je
suppose a fait des chimpanzés qui nous
ressemble vachement pour qu'on croie que
on a dance être en commun avec eux
mais après tout moi si dieu veut que je
crois que j'ai un ancêtre avec avec le
chimpanzé
je vois pas qui je suis pour questionner
sa volonté 1,6 et dieu qui veut que je
crois qu'il ya un ancêtre en commun avec
le chimpanzé en faisant en sorte que les
chimpanzés nous ressemble à ce point je
suis désolé je n'ai pas la prétention
d'être plus intelligent que dieu par
contre la personne qui a fait cette
vidéo elle va certainement me dire le
contraire les personnes qui ont commenté
en dessous aussi en disant que c'était
une superbe vidéo vont certainement
avoir la prétention de me dire le
contraire c'est probablement à pêcher
ils vont probablement devoir faire aussi
pénitence un peu comme je suis en train
de faire en ce moment
bref donc à travers cette douleur que
nous exprimons nous arrivons quand même
apprendre des choses et ça c'est bien
n'oubliez pas c'est
théorie avec un chaînon manquant à aa
c'est drôle c'est drôle on a juste des
milliers de fossiles qui documentent qui
documentent l'évolution humaine depuis
sahelanthropus ya 7 millions d'années en
passant par australopithecus en passant
par homo habilis homo erectus et
delberghe n 6 castle bergin si c'est
ensuite homo sapiens rien que là je vais
te donner les espèces ils sont tous
documenté au moins par un crâne au moins
par un crâne complet et y en a beaucoup
qui sont représentés par plein de
squelettes complets néandertal notamment
donc non les chaînons manquants sont pas
non plus manquants allez bisous et on
passe à la suite un bêta raison va te
coucher way is palme facepalm ce
chimpanzé a tout compris il a absolument
tout compris à cette vidéo
regardez un autre truc qu'on a en commun
avec le chimpanzé
pendant ce temps là dans l'arche de noé
il ya tellement pas de place dans cette
structure gigantesque qu'on est obligé
de filmer à 3 m les gens on est on ne
peut pas regarder ça regardez comme la
caméra est collé au mec qui est en train
de filmer
regardez comment il n'y a pas de place
dans la rage de noël
regardez comme je fais sans landreau
c'est ce mur c'est magnifique
regardez ce bois comme il est frais il
n'a pas du tout passé quatre mille ans
sous la haie lasseubois au nom se boit
il a passé vingt minutes sous la glace à
tout cas j'aimerais bien voir le
documentaire en vrai pour voir s'il ya
un moment on voit les structures en bois
être filmé en même temps que le reste de
la montagne ou en même temps que la
glace touchez pas à un moment où on voit
vraiment que ce truc est en place parce
que ça je veux dire ça pourrait être
filmés en studio que ce serait pareil
hein je veux dire parce que là on la
voit elle est dans la neige
ok mais on filme pas à l'intérieur du
coup on filme vers l'extérieur montre
nous montre ce qui semble être un poteau
électrique
je dis ça tu veux nous faire croire que
c'est un mât de l'arche de noé mais bon
ça pourrait être un poteau ça pourrait
être un pylône électrique que ce serait
pareil
voilà ça sonne beaucoup trop frais pour
être dubois qui a passé quatre mille ans
mais bref voilà là on nous montre un
bout de bois qui est encastrée dans de
la glace mais bon ça pourrait venir de
n'importe où ce truc regarder mais là on
voit presque la glu quoi regarder la
voyez ça c'est de la glace d'un glacier
ça et ça ça et ça et ça regardez c'est
de la glace qui a été fraîchement fondu
un sas et de la glace qui a été
fraîchement fondu comme tout se passe
comme si un jeu ne vais pas faire de
procès d'intention mais tout se passe
comme si quelqu'un était venu avec un
bout de bois avait fait fondre la glace
avait mis le bout de bois est reversé de
l'eau jusqu'à ce que ça gèle le boule de
bois à l'intérieur
assez de la glace tu me fera croire
qu'elle a 4000 ans ça c'est de la glace
tu me feras difficilement croire qu'elle
a plus de quinze jours 1 mais non mais
on souffre pas de la gueule du monde
on se fout pas de la gueule du monde
regardez ce bois à 4000 ans c'est le
parquet de mon grenier
c'est tellement le parquet de mon
grenier qui a encore les le grain
oui car saviez vous le mot grenier vient
du mot grain car on entre opposé du
grain
oui bah j'insère des trivia histoire que
vous que vous appreniez quelque chose en
regardant des conneries comme ça parce
que bon voilà donc je n'ai pas volé
cette image à personne je n'ai
absolument pas volé cette image à
quelqu'un qui qui au contraire feu se
faisait l'avocat de la sélection
naturelle
donc voyez et là encore des plans serrés
des plans serrés et jamais de plan où on
voit la glace et le bois parce que
c'était quand même là où je voulais en
venir à la base bois qui sonne beaucoup
trop creux on se demande pourquoi parce
qu'il n'y a rien derrière parce que
c'est un décor construit certainement
voilà
et tout ça ça se passe soit disant dans
le mont ararat tu vois là
les prophéties sa complice jésus notre
roi et sauveur revient bientôt
c'est vrai c'était les prophéties 10 aix
et les chinois qui trouveraient leur les
prophéties avait totalement dit que
c'étaient les chinois qui trouveraient
l'arche de noé
on n'a rien vu venir voilà et c'est
pareil ils ont retrouvé soi-disant la
structure en bois du bateau non mais
t'es sérieux je veux dire c'est une cave
[Rires]
il ya même de la paille il ya de la
paille
je veux dire c'est une grange ils se
sont ils se sont pointés dans une grange
ou pif
ils ont tourné une toute petite grange à
la con c'est pour ça qu'à regarder là
encore comme ils sont serrés comme des
sardines
une section à l'intérieur du bateau 5 x
12 m
ta ta ta ta ta ta une section à
l'intérieur du bateau 5 x 12 m ça ça
c'est une vue au microscope ça
ça a rien à voir avec une
la vache attendez attendez attendez là
faut que je vérifie un tank
j'aurais bien voilà j'ai fait des
petites recherches pour essayer de
trouver s'il y avait enfin pour essayer
de voir si vraiment ce qu'ils disaient
c'était ce qui prétendait dire j'ai
trouvé cette image alors je voulais a
grandi ici
donc voila voila la façon dont il
présente la structure de l'arche donc
comme je vous disais ah les espaces sont
quand même super exigu 1
à part cet espace-là qui soit disant
fait cinq mètres par 12 voiliers c'est
ce qui a écrit ici cinq mètres par 12
donc ça c'est l'espèce d'entrée qu'on
est censé voir là il ya un gigantesque
espace 5 mètres par 12
on ne les voit jamais filmé à une
distance de 5 m ou de 12 mètres où je
crois que ces douze mètres 5 m de deux
mètres de long 5 mètres de haut
on ne les voit jamais filmé à une telle
distance 1 en tout cas pas sur les
images qu'on nous montre donc cette
chambre la cdu ça pourrait être du
pipeau ce serait pareil et après tous
les autres espaces sont hyper exigus
donc on est d'accord ça c'est censé être
une énorme chambres salas c'est un
morceau de bois au microscope
voyez les fibres du bois on les voit là
les tout petits dés microscopique fibre
de bois là tout ça on les voit là ça
c'est un morceau de bois au microscope
et puis 2 où ils apprennent la photo
d'ailleurs parce que là vous voyez là
c'est soi-disant le sol la voyez le sol
il est ici alors elle est prise de houla
cette photo elle est prise de où ils se
sont envolés pour prendre la photo c'est
ça hein
donc non ça ça en plus vous voyez le ça
se voit aussi au focus je dire le voyez
que le focus là il se fait à ce niveau
là de la photo et là vous voyez c'est
déjà en dehors du focus et on voit quand
je disais là on voit tout les toutes les
fibres tous les petits fils du bois qui
sait qui c'est qui s'est défait ça c'est
une cassure de sur du bois qui a été
prises au microscope
c'est une cassure de bois qui a été
prise en photo microscope et ils ont
juste viré l'échelle et puis ils ont dit
bah ça maintenant c'est une pièce de 12
mètres par 5
je veux dire voilà vos preuves
voilà vos preuves on prend une photo
prise au microscope d'un morceau de bois
et on vous fait croire que c'est un
amphithéâtre de 5 mètres sur 12 par
contre on vous montrera jamais la vidéo
la vidéo où on voit cette pièce et où la
caméra va tout autour de cette pièce et
nous montre l'immensité de cette pièce
vous ne verrez jamais cette image même
si j'ai pas vu le documentaire en entier
je suis certain que vous ne verrez
jamais ce plan parce que cette photo est
un mensonge
il n'y a pas de pièces de 5 mètres par
et cette photo ne l'illustrent pas
donc ça c'est
c'est ridicule à ce point bah ouais
maintenant il ya une petite entrée
maintenant il ya une petite entrée alors
que sur le plan qui nous montre là leur
lente real et là tu vois
mais maintenant il ya une petite entrée
tu sais mais oui bien sûr mais bien sûr
invente les mensonges au fur et à mesure
des râteliers d'animaux à l'intérieur du
bateau avec encore de la paille en place
mais oui mais bien sûr mais bien sûr et
tu vas nous faire croire ça quand quatre
mille ans la paille est resté là aucun
problème sur un côté on peut voir une
planche sera kelly encore les clous
mais oui une planche avec encore et ça
ça c'est la photo que ta prise dans le
grenier de ta grand mère tu sais je vais
prendre une photo dans le grenier de ma
grand mère tu sais dans l'ancienne
bergerie d'à côté et puis on va faire
croire que c'est l'arche de noé vient
chiche
et il ya des gens qui gobent et les
clowns sont pas rouillé évidemment une
section à l'intérieur du bateau couvert
de glace et de cendres volcaniques
voilà et couverts de glace bien fondus
comme il faut un fraîchement fondu
curieusement cette glace de 4000 ans et
curieusement fraîchement fondu quand
elle touche le bois ce qui se voit
encore très très bien d'ailleurs ce qui
se voit encore très très bien juste la
voyez un tout fraîchement fondu là là où
il ya un contact avec le bois c'est
franchement fondu les morceaux de bois a
pris à l'intérieur du bateau oui et
regardez vous imaginez un gros plan
juste là et puis vous avez votre photo
de tout à l'heure des matériaux variés
mais oui
mais tous tellement bien conservé donc
le réchauffement a permis de faire
fondre la glace dans la région et de
libérer l'arche de noé donc c'est quoi
c'était la volonté divine de faire
fondre la glace c'est ça et alors là ce
qui nous montre ses seins
le pop up alors là ce qui nous montre ça
n'a rien à voir avec ce qui vous a
montré tout à l'heure attendez hop voilà
salle à cette structure là
il va essayer de vous faire là il veut
essayer de vous faire croire que ça
c'est le même bateau que celui qui nous
a montré tout à l'heure un large de même
c'est la même arche de noé que celles
qui assurent les images du documentaire
chinois na na nana na na na na ça ça a
rien à voir ça ça vous voyez ça déjà
c'est pas enterré c'est en plein air
d'une de 2 c'est pas du tout recouvert
de glace contrairement à ce qu'on nous
dit depuis tout à l'heure sur l'arche de
noé des chinois mais en plus ça c'est
une autre arche de noé
alors arche de noé parc
je crois que c'est un parent que
maintenant c'est censé être un parc
naturel
arche de noé parc naturel je pense que
si on tape ça on devrait trouver
on devrait préciser en turquie parce
qu'évidemment il ya plein de gens qui
ont fait n'importe quoi avec un voile à
regarder c'est ce truc là
je donnerai comment ça s'appelle ce site
abl voilà le site de dury pinard voilà
voyez cette structure c'est exactement
celle là c'est ça la le site de duru
pinard
duru pinard
attendez on va quand même regarder les
photos pour bien comparer il ya hélas
cette structure là
c'est exactement ce qui vous montre dans
la vidéo mais vu de l'autre côté voyez
le film m et 2 par là donc ça c'est
censé être le site de l'arche de noé
sauf que le site de duru pinard s'est
pas du tout le même site le site de duos
pinard un site montagneux en forme de
bateau la nana qui est situé qui est
situé qui est située
il a été baptisé de long de l'année du
pinard il se trouve près du village de
usain guily à environ trois kilomètres
au nord de la frontière iranienne 15 km
en province et à 22 kilomètres au sud du
mont ararat tu vois là donc voilà le mec
là ils essayent de nous faire passer un
truc qui à 22 km du mont ararat tu pour
le même truc que ce que les chinois ont
trouvé au sommet du mont arafat
1 est ce que tu te foutrais pas de notre
gueule jean mimi
partager cette découverte la plus grand
secret le secret assez dur est vrai ses
secrets donc voilà regardé le magnifique
site de duru pinard du riz pinardon je
suis sûr qu'on a de la géologie
non on n'a pas de la géologie
être dans la version anglaise dans la
version anglaise le site de duru pinard
découverte et l'exploration donc tu as
vite
zoll géophysique east donc voilà il ya
des géologues qui sont partis qui sont
partis à la recherche de enfin qui sont
explorées ce site de duru pinard la
longueur de la formation et à l'aria
soi-disant d encre qui ont été retrouvée
apparemment donc des encres de pierre le
commentateur créationnistes évidemment à
10 face old en 1988 a écrit un livre sur
le site de durée pinardon qu'il existe
un livre entier sur le site de duru
pinard où il dit que c'est le bac c'est
un autre monde celui qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure voilà le monde lui dit se
rappeler vous la photo qu'on a vu tout
au début c'est soit si c'est là que
serait l'arche de noé et pas ailleurs
apparemment donc après l'expédition il
ya des forages qui ont été faits des
fouilles qui ont été faits dans les
années 90 donc phase hall a commencé à
avoir des doutes que du riz pinard était
vraiment le site de l'arche de noé en 94
il y aller avec le géologue australien
ian pin maire qui a conclu que ce
n'était pas un bateau et sur miles dote
donc ancien people donc ils ont
évidemment cru que c'était un bateau par
le passé et ils ont écrit ensemble un
article avec le géologue
donc là il ya eu des géologues qui sont
venus voir contrairement un truc des
chinois là où il ya encore aucun
scientifique n'est personne à part
l'équipe de tournage qui est allé là il
ya des géologues qui sont venus et il a
écrit un article ce géologue qui
s'appelle bo gus noah's ark from turquie
exposé à ce common géologique structure
donc l'arche de noé la fosse arche de
noé de turquie qui est con qui est en
fait une structure géologique très
commode très très commune et qui conclut
que la structure en forme de bateau
n'est pas du tout un bateau et qui dit
aussi que les encres en fait sont des
roches volcaniques tout à fait locale
il est où l'article il ya un lien vers
l'article will i am alive voilée
regardez ça c'est une belle publication
scientifique avec des titres
avec des gens des vrais géologue dans
les hauteurs une date un titre un
journal of giants éducation voilà et un
dowie un dowie ça c'est beau ça parce
que ça permet de trouver très facilement
les papiers voilà donc le voilà journal
of géosciences et du kitchen vous
trouvez l'article instantanément il
n'est pas en accès libre mais
heureusement
yahia ben ça y est l'ami de tous les
chercheurs pas les chercheurs de vérité
les vrais chercheurs mais seulement si
tu lui copie colle un dow est valide par
contre si non il va pas y arriver
les deux oui ça commence toujours par le
chiffre 10 6 jeux mais si j'oublie
décrire voilà donc c'est elle qui a créé
ça ira donc fait lui coucou voilà et
vous voyez donc un magnifique article
qui nous parle de cette structure
géologique qui en fait l'analyse donc ça
ça va être les fameuse encre de pierre
dont il parlait tout à l'heure la ces
trucs là et on voit si ce qu'est un
synclinal voyez là c'est exactement la
même structure que ce que vous voyez là
tac
sauf que c'est un synclinal voilà c'est
donc là vous avez la roche épaisse comme
ça en forme de sourire et les roches
plus fine à l'intérieur qui ont été
pliées par les mouvements géologiques
parce qu'évidemment on est dans une zone
de montagne a eu donc eu beaucoup de
mouvements géologiques et donc en
surface
ça c'est en vue de côté et donc en
surface ça ressemble à une lentille en
fait et c'est exactement comme ça et ça
vous explique du coup par là même au cas
où vous seriez sceptiques de ce que je
suis en train de vous raconter ça vous
explique aussi par là même pourquoi tout
autour il ya à peu près la même chose
voyez que là il ya un autre mur là et
puis là il ya un autre mur ici et puis
là il ya un mur qui part sur le côté ici
voyez c
et c'est cette structure géologique
parmi tant d'autres structures
géologiques qui lui ressemble tout
autour et si on regarde d'autres images
je suis sûr qu'on en voit si on revient
sur ces images là la fameuse caméra qui
monte est là
voilà donc vous voyez ici là vous avez
cette espèce de structure en forme de
bateau c'est de la roche qui a tout
autour c'est pas du bois et là vous avez
le même type de roche ici et là vous
avez encore un autre team le même type
de roche encore ici et là vous avez
encore le même type de roche encore ici
vous voyez si on met ses oeillères
évidemment on voit que le bateau mais
une fois qu'on ouvre les yeux et qu'on
regarde le paysage le même type de roche
se retrouvent tout autour et on y voit
très bien que c'est une structure
en synclinal voilà et donc la structure
en synclinal donc ici vous avez le
sourire qui passent en dessous là c'est
pas c'est pas ça le sourire mais le
sourire en fait il est là il passe en
dessous comme ça et vous avez des roches
plus tendres ici une roche très dure qui
passe comme ça et puis hop cette roche
dure elle repart dans la dans le sol ici
en fait est là tout ça ça a été érodée
mais ça et ça c'est la même roche
c'est juste la roche qui repart vers le
bas ici et là pareil vous avez la roche
très dure
hop et à leur part vers le bas ici
exactement comme ce qui vous montre la
voilà la roche dure up qui repart vers
le bas la roche dure qui repart vers le
bas c'est ça la fameuse de structurant
synclinal c'est juste du caillou et les
analyses ouais donc analyse par électron
par microscope électronique à balayage
qui est censé venir d'un morceau de fer
et qui en fait composé en partie de
silice donc ce qui montre bien que c'est
du caillou quoi re effectivement il a dû
faire il a dû fermer ses du fer naturel
quoi c'est pas du fer qui a été c'est
pas du fer qui a été qui a été qui a été
modifiée par l'être humain donc
l'appareil analyse delà de la roche de
cette de cette roche ici de cette encre
donc ils ont fait une analyse chimique
et ils ont conclu que c'est juste du
caillou ya rien de spécial avec cette
encre voilà donc les conclusions
l'analyse microscopique les photos
démontrent que l'arche est une roche
complètement naturel ça ne peut pas être
l'arche de noé
note il n'aime pas un modèle fait par
l'homme a posteriori ces genres ta
gueule ta gueule j'ai raison voilà
appareils interprétation les roches
volcaniques similaire à l'an daisy donc
c'est alan dsit des encres sont présents
dans la zone autour du mont ararat tu
n'as presque totale absence de roches
volcaniques en mésopotamie
e ou l'arche de noé est supposé avoir
été construite et limite élimine
raisonnablement la possibilité que ces
encres ont été transportés transportés
depuis la mésopotamie par l'arche de noé
jusqu'au moins c'est de la pierre locale
donc ça ne peut pas être une encre qui a
été fabriqué là où l'arche de noé a été
fabriquée en soi disant fabriquer non
boum
donc voilà il ya de la littérature
scientifique en plus là dessus donc là
t'as aucune excuse aucune excuse non
seulement tu essayes de nous faire
croire que ça c'est la même chose que ce
qui est dans le documentaire chinois
mais en plus tu n'as aucune excuse il ya
de la documentation scientifique
il ya même une page wikipédia là dessus
et là regardez il en reparle des drogues
stone là en disant que ce sont encore
une fois l'âge et l'investigation
géologique par lawrence collins a montré
que ces roches ne pouvait pas avoir été
fabriqué en mésopotamie qui est supposé
être l'endroit où l'arche a été
construite et alors là le pire
similaire stonesoft route unchained
armenia haricots d'alsace pagano
l'histone ce conte vingtaine tout
christiane used by a dit shawn of claus
is over clichés symbols manière found in
christiane sa maîtrise à se disent
ouverts
donc ça ça veut dire que deux des roches
comme cet entre soi disant sont trouvés
communément en arménie donc ça donc ça
confirme que c'est de la roche locales
et elles ont été convertis en pire
sainte donc la holy stone pierre sainte
parler christine par les chrétiens qui
ont dessiné des croix dessus
et beaucoup de ces pierres sont trouvés
dans des cimetières
donc bravo +1 pour la profanation de
cimetière voilà donc voilà ce que ce que
vous prenez pour des encres c'est en
fait des pierres tombales
+1 pour la profanation de cimetière bien
joué les gars donc en caution dans cette
vidéo la toux les gens là qui ont aimé
cette vidéo là en cautionnant cette
vidéo vous cautionnez la profanation de
cimetière bien joué bien joué voilà donc
cette vidéo vous ment cette vidéo ne
fait pas que se tromper donc non
seulement elle utilise une méthode
complètement tombé au début pour vous
dira genre le mont ararat c'est la seule
montagne avec de la glace c'est
magnifique c'est un miracle mais en plus
ils vous présentent ce documentaire
chinois comme étant la découverte de
l'arche
alors que ce documentaire vous ment
aussi parce qu ils vous montrent des
trucs censés être des pièces de 4 mètres
par 12 tout temps
tout en prenant vous montrant au passage
une photo d'un truc qui est prise au
microscope
mais c'est juste qu'ils ont enlevés
l'échelle dessus donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut mettre une échelle sur ces
images d'ailleurs un c'est pour pas que
les gens croient que vous montrer des
trucs qui font quatre mètres par 12
alors que ça fait un demi millimètre et
en plus à la fin ils essayent de vous
faire croire que regarder on la retrouve
l arche de noé toute entière alors qu'en
fait c'est pas du tout la même structure
c'est une structure qui se trouve à des
dizaines de kilomètres de là soit
disantes arche de noé dont il vous a
parlé au début
bravo bravo c'était de la merde s'était
sérieusement de la merde
bon et puis regarde juste à la fin tu
seras sauvé alors là j'ai peur mais en
gros je crois qu'il ya plus de science
là c'est juste des extraits de mauvais
sitcom reconstitution de la vie
est-ce que c'est pas la vie de brian ça
ce serait marrant qu'il ait pris des
extraits de la vie de brian
pour faire son espèce de montage à la
noix la fin là mais en gros voilà
propagande religieuse sur la fin et
génériques
et je ne saurais pas sauvé ma pénitence
aura servi à rien parce que j'ai pas
regardé jusqu'à la fin
préparez-vous by people
j'arrive bientôt signer jésus christ
signé jésus-christ sur fond rose
signée jésus-christ sur fond rouge
mètres du nouveau de chanel maître du
maître du bullshit chanal voilà c'était
c'était mes derniers commentaires sur
cette vidéo
c'était des bunkers et pénitence je vous
remercie pas de m'obliger à faire des
choses comme ça et à très bientôt